young knows the winner and our buddy
Mark Broussard from the NBA knows the
winner but I don't know what's in the
envelope would you do the honors jet of
announcing our winner Jerry West is one
of my favorite players of all time and
one of the nicest people indeed so and
people
the
Kia
2023 clutch Player of the Year award
goes to
the Aaron Fox from the Sacramento Kings
and he's proven it last night oh yeah
this obviously is a regular season award
but he doesn't have the most clutch
swipe at a fox as uh as he's known out
there in Sacramento uh the winner of the
NBA's clutch Player of the Year
congratulations on winning that Jerry
West trophy it's going to look good
isn't it thank you I appreciate it yeah
it's definitely uh definitely going to
get added to the memorabilia room hey uh
look we know when you win something like
this a lot of this is mindset I mean
there are a lot of talented players not
everybody wants the ball uh when it's
clutch time what what triggers in you
that says this is your time
I always tell people you got to be you
can't be afraid to fail
um obviously you're not going to make
every shot
but my teammates my coaches they put me
in position uh to succeed so the least I
can do is have confidence in myself to
go take big shots Darren check here a
lot of us experts were kind of concerned
about the youthfulness of this team but
my question to you is you know having a
young team how do you guys have so much
voice
uh I mean we have a guy who's been an
All-Star who's been in uh the playoffs
before HB he's big for us he's been
extremely vocal since the playoffs has
started and uh we have Mike who's won a
championship on multiple teams as a
coach so
um he helps us do it all
well Darren first of all there's no such
thing as an expert she acts just wrong
that's why I said so-called experts yes
okay hey so coach Mike Brown you guys
kind of been in the wilderness the last
few years what is Coach Brown giving you
to make this the whole thing come
together
man accountability accountability was
big from day one
um when he was hired I told him that's
the that's the most important thing I
feel like to me uh was just being able
to hold everybody accountable so uh from
the day he was hired he's gotten on me
he's gotten on domos and once you see us
being willing to be coached then he's
like the rest of the players just fall
in line so
um that was probably that's definitely
the biggest thing is he'll he'll pull
somebody out quick I think the quickest
time body called this year was like 31
seconds and it was only because we got
the ball first
[Laughter]
stations on the award first the iron
secondly you know you talk about
inexperience or experience of the
playoffs personally what has been the
most unique thing about the playoffs
that Dave you have expected or did not
expect
man the physicality physicality it's
they let a lot of things go in the
playoffs and it's funny the first half
of the first game I think I was three
for nine and I was
I was trying to figure out
you know how do I play through this and
uh the second half I figured it out but
yeah the physicality is definitely the
biggest thing
um that's that's different from the
regular season to the playoffs
Darren we like to think that all great
players uh think alike when you go up
against a player with the caliber of a
Stephen Curry do you say to yourself I'm
gonna go at this candidate you say to
yourself I'm just going to play my game
or whatever happens happens
nah you definitely got to go out there
and play your game you don't want to get
into a shootout with somebody like Steph
but at the same time playing point guard
in this league uh you you gotta you
gotta match up every single day no
matter who you're playing against you're
going against someone who's extremely
talented so but I think like I said my
teammates and my team put me in position
to succeed so regardless of who I'm
going up against we're always confident
dear and when you win something like
this who's the first person you want to
tell about it
ah
probably my wife yeah definitely my wife
uh obviously she's usually around me
anyway so I don't have to tell her she
probably hears it when I hear it but
yeah definitely her first
congratulations from all of us here
um a well-deserved honor obviously and
and the numbers prove that out and the
performance when the game is on the line
proves that out so dearan Fox
congratulations we appreciate you taking
some